this morning the return of America's
elephants that's how many refer to wood
bison the largest land mammal found in
North America wood bison were declared
extinct in the 1900s until a tiny herd
was found in a remote section of Canada
that Discovery helped launch a program
that has reintroduced these Giants in
the U.S to see them up close we visited
the Alaska Wildlife Conservation Center
an hour outside Anchorage
[Music]
additional grazing crazy from a distance
they look just like prairie bison that
quintessential symbol of the American
West
but get a little closer and you realize
would bison are the super-sized version
I often relate these guys to the North
America's version of the elephant Sarah
Howard runs the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center the social
hierarchies and the behaviors that they
display they're a lot like an elephant
in that way it's just really cool to be
in the presence of a bison for as long
as we know wood bison roam the plains of
North America the indigenous athabascan
people of Alaska relied on them for food
and shelter for more than ten thousand
years
until in the late 1800s and early 1900s
the wood bison disappeared they were
thought to be extinct
about 65 years ago a small herd was
found in a remote section of Northern
Canada
from that batch the wood bison
reintroduction program was eventually
born these guys being grazers Alaska
doesn't have any grazers we think about
moose and moose are actually browsers
that means they eat Woody vegetation
they're not on the ground eating all the
grasses and sedges so having a bison
back out there just creates a healthier
environment it creates a healthier
ecosystem from animals the size of Bison
all the way down to the voles and the
mice five new calves have been born this
spring to go along with 2021's yearlings
what's this one's name
this is I think 307 307 is last year's
baby
pretty sure 307 is sapphire Sapphire
yeah we had gemstones last year do you
like the food
it looks like you didn't get them oh oh
geez we're getting aggressive wow yeah
yeah I'm talking about you
you don't need to be pawing the ground
at us
I gave you that cube in a nice manner
don't look at me like that
I'm here to feed you I so much enjoyed
the show oh wonderful Sarah Howard has
become a bit of a celebrity in recent
years following the debut of the reality
show Alaska animal rescue which
highlighted the work sheener colleagues
are doing I'll give her a couple try
eyes and if she doesn't take it then
I'll have to call the vet and see what
she wants us to do the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center provides safe
habitats for everything from Caribou to
wolves to bears
but today the unquestioned star is the
wood bison the focus of not just a
rescue but a complete Revival so this is
that first time Mom and that's her first
baby and that baby's only three weeks
old
I lived here every day and stayed with
the Bison every day to prepare them for
transport into the wild Darren Bruning
is a biologist with the Alaska
Department of Fish and Game he's been
working on this program since its
Inception
16 years ago they built a sanctuary here
where wood bison could successfully
breed in captivity
by 2015 the first herd of more than a
hundred bison were successfully released
in the wild
330 miles Northwest of Anchorage using a
C-130 plane how do you transport a 2 000
pound grumpy
wood bison one step at a time
with a lot of patience and
taking it very slowly
why is it so important now that wood
bison are back
It's a grand opportunity for restoration
of a missing piece of our incredible
landscape
since being reintroduced wood bison have
had their challenges including two
especially brutal winners
but the program continues working away
and to have them back at all is
something almost no one imagined just a
generation ago what does all this mean
for you personally
I truly can't believe I get to be part
of this it it is an amazing it's a dream
come true for me
and they just let us know in the last
couple days that just this week 28 more
would advice
all the time but the goal the goal of
the center overall for every animal is
to if they can to get them back out if
it can be done safely what an incredible
piece wow yeah the work that they're
doing there Majestic animals they really
are when I was up in Montana doing the
Buffalo story and the reintroduction
there from Canada it's it's important to
get them back into their native Native
working space